ahora que ya hemos hablado de la
epidermis la capa más externa de nuestra
piel de sentamos para hablar de la
dermis las siguientes dos capas de
nuestra piel para finalizar hablando de
la hipodermis que es la capa más
inferior de nuestra piel como puedes ver
nuestra dermis tiene dos capas y vamos a
escribir que estamos justo debajo de la
epidermis recordemos la capa inferior de
nuestra epidermis se llama estrato basal
abajo de ella tenemos la primera capa de
la dermis que se llama estrato papilar
esta es la capa superior de la dermis
debajo del estrato papilar tenemos lo
que se conoce como estrato reticular la
gran diferencia entre la dermis y la
epidermis es el tipo de tejido que
tienen recordemos que en la epidermis
tenemos tejido epitelial mientras que en
la dermis tenemos tejido conectivo el
tejido conectivo se diferencia en que no
necesariamente involucra células en el
tejido epitelial hay cosas como células
epiteliales escamosas simples células
epiteliales columnares e incluso células
epiteliales de transición que tal vez
hemos visto en la vejiga pero el tejido
conectivo contiene una letanía de
distintas proteínas
y la actina de la que hablamos en el
sistema muscular o el colágeno que es
otra proteína estructural
estas son algunas de las proteínas más
populares que se mencionan cuando
hablamos del tejido conectivo pero
también hay otras como la la mínina la
elastina y la des mina
el tejido conectivo principalmente
mantiene las cosas juntas recordemos los
tendones los tendones un tejido
conectivo que une el músculo al hueso y
entre el estrato papilar y el estrato
reticular hay dos tipos de tejido
conectivo que observamos en el estrato
papilar tenemos un tejido conectivo muy
delgado y laxo
y esto permite que todas las cosas en
este estrato puedan moverse por él y
cambiar de forma y posición mientras que
el estrato reticular es un tejido
conectivo más grueso y denso su
propósito es hacer que las cosas se
queden quietas en el estrato reticular
anclamos las cosas en un momento
hablaremos de lo que anclamos por aquí
primero hablaremos del estrato para
pilar y de las cosas que tenemos aquí
que van a cambiar de forma y posición ya
que el tejido conectivo aquí es más laxo
una de las cosas que encontraremos en el
estrato papilar son los vasos sanguíneos
si recuerdas las arterias se pueden
planificar en arteriolas que forman los
capilares que pondremos en color morado
y después se unen para formar las
células que a su vez se unen en una vena
ahora podemos darnos cuenta de que esta
es la capa de piel más superficial o más
externa que tiene vasos sanguíneos
entonces uno de sus roles es que estos
capilares entregan el oxígeno y los
nutrientes para abastecer no sólo a la
dermis sino que también suben a la
epidermis recordemos que la epidermis no
tiene vasos sanguíneos se pasa por
completo en la dermis papilar para
nutrirse tenemos la fortuna de que este
tejido conectivo es delgado y laxo
porque esto nos da mucho espacio para
que los capilares se hinchen de sangre
llena de nutrientes y estos nutrientes
se difundan a través de la dermis y
suban a la epidermis e incluso bajen a
si es necesario
otra cosa que tenemos en la dermis son
terminaciones nerviosas estas
terminaciones nerviosas que estoy
intentando dibujar aunque mi dibujo no
sea muy bueno nos permiten percibir
cosas como el tacto o incluso dolor esas
sensaciones pasarán en una señal a
través del nervio en esta dirección y
esta señal se transmitirá todo el camino
hasta un cuerpo celular de una neurona
que puede encontrarse en algún lugar muy
muy alejado de la piel
ahora vayamos al estrato reticular o
dermis reticular y veamos por qué es
importante tener un tejido conectivo
grueso y denso este tejido conectivo nos
ayuda a anclar las cosas una de las
cosas que podemos tener y lo vamos a
dibujar así ascendiendo por la epidermis
hasta salir por aquí es una glándula
tenemos muchas glándulas sudoríparas y
glándulas exocrinas y de otras
variedades que empiezan en el estrato
reticular y están ancladas aquí pero se
extienden por un ducto para secretar sus
contenidos a la epidermis y al mundo
exterior entonces tenemos muchas
glándulas por aquí y además tenemos
folículos de este folículo emerge un
pelo el pelo va a sobresalir de la piel
no es que solo tengamos un pelo que esté
adentro ya que está acompañado de este
de aquí
es un folículo piloso o el folículo de
nuestro pelo
este folículo está anclado a la dermis
reticular mientras que el pelo crecerá y
se extenderá hacia arriba hasta salir
por la parte superior y sobresalir de la
epidermis otra de las cosas que tenemos
en nuestra dermis ancladas al folículo
piloso es este bloque muscular que se
conoce como músculo elector del pelo y
está involucrado con extender o mantener
tu pelo firme cuando hace frío o tienes
miedo para finalizar una vez que
terminamos de hablar de la dermis
podemos pasar a nuestra última capa de
piel aunque técnicamente no es piel pero
se llama hipodermis como recordaremos
hipo significa por debajo entonces esta
capa está por debajo de la dermis a esta
misma capa también se le conoce con el
nombre de tejido celular subcutáneo o
tejido panículo adiposo que también son
buenos nombres para esta capa observemos
que la palabra subcutáneo se forma de
cutáneo que hace referencia a la piel y
suv es un prefijo que nos indica por
debajo de 10 tipos o hace referencia a
lípidos entonces tejido celular
subcutáneo o panículo adiposo son
nombres adecuados ya que tenemos muchas
capas de tejidos adiposos que pueden
variar de persona a persona por debajo
de la dermis ya pesar de que el tejido
adiposo tiene muy mala fama tenemos que
darnos cuenta de que es muy importante
ya que tiene dos funciones fundamentales
primero la grasa absorbe el impacto las
personas están más aisladas gracias a la
grasa y son capaces de soportar lesiones
traumáticas de manera más efectiva
y la otra función que tiene es aislar
nuestro tejido ahora nos damos cuenta de
que hemos terminado de hablar de la piel
hemos hablado de la epidermis de la
dermis y ahora estamos estudiando la
hipodermis que tenemos debajo de ella
bueno debajo de ella encontraremos
músculo el músculo está debajo de esta
capa y más abajo seguramente hay hueso
si pensamos en nuestra pared torácica
justo arriba de la costilla y ponemos un
dedo donde está la clavícula arriba de
la caja torácica o incluso en las
costillas podemos notar que nuestra
epidermis nuestra dermis y nuestra
hipodermis separan a nuestro dedo de las
costillas o incluso del músculo si ahora
presionamos el bíceps o por ejemplo en
la pantorrilla y ya hemos pasado mucho
tiempo hablando de las componentes de
nuestra piel pero como nos ayuda a esto
clínicamente como usan estos los
doctores para darnos
y una enfermedad la mejor forma para
hablar de esto es con un ejemplo vamos a
hablar del diagnóstico de quemaduras una
quemadura es una cosa horrible que puede
suceder y una de las cosas que hacemos
para saber qué tipo de quemadura tenemos
es decir el grado de la quemadura
curiosamente es fijarnos en las
diferentes capas de la piel ya que éstas
corresponden a los diferentes grados de
quemaduras que se pueden tener una
quemadura de primer grado es una especie
de enrojecimiento que ocurre en la
epidermis una quemadura del segundo
grado se caracteriza por quemaduras en
la dermis tanto que no hay dolor
nervioso después de un tiempo esa es la
diferencia entre la quemadura de primer
grado y una quemadura de segundo grado
la quemadura de primer grado duele mucho
pero si existe una parte que fue quemada
y que dejó de doler tanto es porque el
tejido nervioso de aquí se quemó y murió
por lo tanto no puede mandar una señal
al cuerpo celular de la neurona
finalmente una quemadura de tercer grado
es aquella que pasa a la hipodermis ya
sea el tejido adiposo o en el músculo
debajo de él o incluso en el hueso una
quemadura de tercer grado se caracteriza
por no tener dolor y tener una
coloración más oscura
porque se ha quemado más que solo el
tejido conectivo se han quemado también
los músculos o huesos o tejido adiposo
bien hemos hablado de esta anatomía
exacta que permite a los doctores
distinguir si un paciente presenta una
quemadura de primer grado segundo grado
o tercer grado y ahora tú también puedes
entenderlo